[Musique]
l'aquarius barreaux un bateau affrété
par sos méditerranée a recueilli ce 9
juin 629 personnes dont 123 enfants
mineurs isolés
cette femme enceinte qui était sur
plusieurs navires de fortune au péril de
leur vie
l'italie a dit nous avons pu accueillir
tous ces migrants l'espagne s'est
déclarée prête à le faire mais la france
elle est restée muette ce qu'a dénoncé
d'ailleurs notamment une madame sonia
crimi députés de la majorité à laquelle
vous dit appartenir notre ma question
est simple monsieur le premier ministre
la france est elle prête à respecter son
devoir humanitaire
celui que le président de la république
avait décrié avec madame merkel le 23
juin 2017
nous serons avec le président de la
république à berlin mardi prochain pour
dire ce que devraient être les règles
d'une coopération européenne en matière
de migration j'ai par ailleurs eu le
ministre italien de l'intérieur à qui
j'ai rappelé qu'il convenait d'avoir des
règles européennes communes et en
particulier le respect des accords de
coopération qui existait entre la france
et l'italie
l'article 13 du règlement de dublin
oblige censément l'italie à instruire
les demandes d'asile de toutes ces
personnes le président de la république
lui même a dit il y a un an
il faut qu'on trouve une réponse et vous
vous continuez à vous évertuez à faire
appliquer ce règlement de dublin qui ne
tient pas comment bouger vous en europe
que faites-vous connurent bouge rien
nous en reparlerons la semaine prochaine
sur votre soin asile immigration qui
effectivement n'a qu'un but c'est de
laisser les immigrants
les demandeurs d'asile à l'extérieur au
risque ce qu'ils se noient merci à
l'espagne bravo à la france nous avons
appris avec stupéfaction et colère que
le rapport islamistes médine allait se
produire sur la scène du bataclan en
octobre prochain
cet homme n'a guère posé avec un tee
shirt portant la mention djihad en
lettres d'or sur fond noir que le
rappeur diffuse sans jamais avoir été
inquiété ses textes d'appel à la haine
est déjà en soi problématique mais qu'il
se produise au bataclan ou des
djihadistes ont causé plus de 130 morts
et où plus de 400 blessés vivent avec
des blessures est évidemment un scandale
beaucoup plus grand
la loi est très simple elle ne peut elle
ne permet d'interdire le cas échéant que
lorsque la programmation causerait un
trouble manifeste à l'ordre public et
qu'aucun mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le seul trait vous plaît laissez le
premier ministre poursuivent
la loi est claire incitation à la haine
raciale ou trouble manifeste à l'ordre
public voilà les deux seuls fondement
qui pourrait justifier une mesure nous
respecterons donc scrupuleusement et la
liberté d'expression et la loi si la
ligne du gouvernement
c'est la ligne du gouvernement et lula
tiendront en en étant aussi attaché
aussi attaché au respect de la loi
qu'allah qu'à la mémoire de ce cas la
mémoire de ceux qui ont trouvé la mort
ou qui étaient présents ce soir là
[Musique]